Speaker 1: Hey, a couple of months ago, I
interviewed this.
Trump endorsed Republican House candidate
J.R.
Maju Ski.
We spoke about a lot of things with Jay Ahmed.
You ski in some areas.
He was quite radical.
In others, he was not quite so radical.
But we have now learned that, Jared, You Ski
has completely fabricated his supposed record
as a military veteran who served in Afghanistan
multiple times.
This is Stolen Valor, folks, multiple times.
J.R.
Maju ski has said I did serve in Afghanistan.
It turns out that he did.
This was, if I understand correctly, broken
by the Associated Press in which Brian slew
disco and James LaPorta wrote J.R.
Maju Ski presents himself as an Air Force
Air Force combat veteran deployed to Afghanistan
after 911, once describing, quote, tough conditions,
including a lack of running water, forcing
him to go more than 40 days without a shower.
Military documents obtained by the AP tell
a different story.
Maju Ski never deployed to Afghanistan.
He did six months loading planes at an airbase
in Qatar.
That's an ally.
It was very safe from any fighting.
Magic Sky's account of his time in the military
is only one aspect of his bio that suspect,
his post-military career has been defined
by exaggerations.
Conspiracy theories, talk of violent action
against the U.S. government and occasional
financial duress.
Thanks to an unflinching allegiance to Trump,
he also stands a chance of defeating the longtime
Democratic Congresswoman Marcy Kaptur.
Now, listen, this guy is out of his mind.
And we knew that from the interview I did
with him.
He has no business being a member of the House.
I hope that these lies.
Yes, this is stolen valor.
I hope that these lies about his military
service end up torpedoing his campaign.
He should he should just drop out.
He probably won't.
Let's take a look at some clips.
Here is J.R.
Mmajunkie claiming that he did a tour of duty
in Afghanistan, but he doesn't really like
to talk about it.
What a humble guy, huh?
Speaker 3: Did you serve in Afghanistan?
Yes.
Speaker 1: Did you serve in Afghanistan?
Yes, I did.
That is a lie.
Okay, I'm just going to play it once more
so that there's no ambiguity here about whether
he lied.
Speaker 3: Did you serve in Afghanistan?
Yes, I did.
How many tours?
One.
What year were you there?
What year?
2022.
23.
Wow.
So you served right at the beginning?
Yeah.
What was that experience like?
Tough.
I don't like talking about my mom.
Speaker 1: It was really tough when he was
in Afghanistan.
Never happened.
Just a lie through experience.
Speaker 3: Not.
Not.
Not that.
Not that we've said too much.
I just don't.
I don't really like to.
I really don't like to divulge a lot of things
about the military because, you know, they're
to me, you know, it was a it was a tough time
in life.
You know, the military wasn't easy, but in
retrospect, it's one of the best decisions
I've ever made.
Speaker 1: It's a folks.
He loaded planes in Qatar for six months.
That's what he did.
There was no tough experience in Afghanistan.
Now, as far as his claim that he didn't shower
for 40 days, maybe that's true, but it certainly
wasn't because there was no running water.
Here is another example of this, wherein he
says that he he he it's something it's it's
a really detailed story about playing video
games in Afghanistan.
He was never in Afghanistan.
It's just a lie.
Speaker 3: X-Box and and be on that thing
to like midnight just talking and shooting
people man.
It was fun.
But I also remember now that I'm thinking
about that.
But yeah, we played the Division Man for forever
and then the Division two game came out and
we just kind of got we just, you know, we
played it for like a month or two and it wasn't
the same, so we would quit.
But I remember being in the desert and writing
in Afghanistan and.
Speaker 1: That is a lie.
He was not in Afghanistan.
Speaker 3: Somebody's mom sent a PlayStation
two or something like that over with Grand
Theft Auto.
Speaker 1: And anyway, you get the point.
So the point is he was playing video games
when he was in Afghanistan.
And then there's a whole bunch of these a
whole bunch of these examples of him just
lying.
Here's another one.
Speaker 3: Did she serve in the military?
No.
She and you did.
You were Air Force.
Okay.
You served in Operation Enduring Freedom,
correct?
Absolutely.
Afghanistan.
Yes, sir.
Speaker 1: Yes, sir.
In Afghanistan, it's just another lie.
And I could even find, find, find more of
these.
And they are quite despicable, in fact.
Just to be thorough.
There was one more here.
Yeah.
Here.
He actually he says he lost his grandmother
when he was in Afghanistan.
Speaker 3: I have no regrets in my life.
One or two.
And those those regrets are, you know, if
I could do them over.
It would be things that I didn't know I could
have control, you know?
Yeah.
But, you know, the most important thing that
ever happened probably is I lost my grandmother
when I was in Afghanistan, and I didn't.
I didn't get to see her.
Speaker 1: That that.
He was in in Afghanistan now.
Did he lose his grandmother while he was in
Qatar?
Maybe.
But that's a totally different story.
That's not combat.
So by the standards of Republicans, this guy
should be forced to drop out.
Not a single Republican should be voting for
this guy.
Republicans claim that we should revere our
veterans.
Now, of course, they don't do it.
We don't even provide good medical care in
many cases to our veterans, although the VA
does the best it can.
We really leave behind veterans in many ways
when it comes to jobs as well.
But forget about the fact that they don't
really mean it.
Stolen valor.
Should be the end of the road for these Republicans.
And yet, Jamba Juice, he might still win his
race.
Horrible stuff.
And really good reporting by the AP and others
figuring out that this guy apparently made
up the entire thing.
Let me know what you think.
Find me on Twitter at Pacman.
Remember that the David Pakman show is a community
and audience funded program.
You can support the work we do through the
membership program and you can sign up at
Join PACT Mint.com.
The list of benefits is extensive, but at
the top of the list is the bonus show.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else who makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Every day we do an extra show for
our members and I encourage you to sign up
and join back